our alternative to low wages
increase the minimum wage to 15 euros per hour
and let all benefits and the state pension rise
two million people work in the Netherlands
for the minimum wage
and can hardly,
if at all,
make ends meet
certainly considering all those rising energy prices
shopping prices
it is urgently needed that finally after forty years
wages rise faster
than the profits of the companies
and it is also positive for the economy
because when wages go up
people can also spend more
and there, for example,
it also benefits
small and medium-sized businesses of
so that all those people who work in the slaughterhouses
in the distribution centers
the postmen the cleaners
all of that
can continue to pay for their groceries